we make very high-end water sport
enthusiast toys and we make a wide
variety of boats for wake surfing and
wakeboarding
I'm the president CEO of Master Craft
Master crap chooses to produce here in
Tennessee because of such a great
availability to labor it's a very
competitive wage environment for us this
is a low cost place to manufacture large
majority of our dealers are on the East
Coast there certainly has been a push to
manufacture abroad however for our
product we think the control quality
it's critical for us to manufacture and
supply locally this word a workingman
builds things you want to built right
you got to build it in America he's kind
of see happens to be a boat building
mecca the easy access to water you can
literally go anywhere in the world from
this waterway hook up to the Tennessee
River which is only about ten miles from
here take it right on down and hook up
into the Mississippi folks are built
from the outside in
they're actually built out of a mold so
we spray the colors that you see on the
outside they go in the mold first then
it's reinforced with fiberglass and we
pull it out of the mold so the boats
really built on it in two parts the deck
and the hall when the work is completed
we literally pick the deck up roll the
hole underneath it and place the deck
down on the hall and we screw and pin it
together I think that people would be
surprised at how labour and sense that
the boats are takes a lot of man hours
in order to get that done we don't have
any robots here there's no better skill
set than the people here now it starts
to look like the boat that you're
familiar with not only is the
performance of the boat important for
our customer but what happens behind the
boat is equally as important this is the
fun part of the job we water test every
single boat that we
we're actually out on Celico Leite
adjacent small property we're gonna get
to enjoy a little bit of surfing boating
really a lifestyle we get to do what we
generally love every single day it's not
work